hey what's up folks down here i'm in
orlando florida the most humid place in
the goddamn world it's like the sauna
broke why am I in orlando florida what
possible reason would I have to come all
the way to orlando florida for one day
well you might remember a couple of
months ago I had to go all the way to
Cologne in Germany at Gamescom to get my
hands on WWE 2k15 that's where I talked
to the Big Show and asking a lot of
stupid questions we got a little bit of
time at the game there but they're being
sort of crazily tight with this game
like it wasn't until last week when that
trailer came in to be actually saw
gameplay although I feel like calling
that gameplay might be a little bit a
little bit on troop is always always
sort of the cutscenes they show but
we're starting to get a look at the sort
of next-gen wrestling game a lot of
people are wondering what the game is
likes we've come all the way out here to
orlando sweat piss I wish I wore shorts
real sticky down there yeah back up but
I I'm here in the in the WWE Performance
Center is a bunch of superstars here a
bunch of NXT superstars in the making
here as well build the motts here and so
we're gonna talk to those folks a little
bit about their careers about the game
and finally I get to have a go at the
new career most that enjoy w 2k15 so
come join us sweaty in the interest of
transparency it should be noted that
this whole thing was organized it funded
by 2k they flew at Orlando they brought
us to the WWE Performance Center which
is where the whole demo took place and
they also gave us this entertaining if
totally redundant store of a university
that helps them broadcast NXT
none of that was filmed we didn't film
almost missing our connecting flight in
Dallas we didn't film poor Andy
Steadicam rig never actually making it
to Orlando and we didn't film the two
hours sleep we got before having another
six hours of flights and airports on the
way back on Friday the film was a bunch
of interviews with superstars about how
the WWE Performance Center and NXT is in
the new WWE 2k15 s career mode and I
actually got to play this elusive game
for more than five minutes
come on pleasure to meet you sir hugh
Mars himself oh my gosh it is me it's
you how are you doing this is the
performance and as your baby what's it
like heaven having it actually in the
video game it's unbelievable it's
fascinating to think what it's what the
what the gaming system has come to and
then to see the performance and are a
part of it and they always go by I saw
the red wall on the game never goes yeah
but you're in it like oh yeah that's
cool but did you see the seven rings and
they were yeah but bill you're in the
game e your call yeah that's great but
you see what we get to do in the game I
saw like the air conditioning system was
a son the banners are up there word for
word it's my nose dome ok like you know
something about the nose it replicates a
simulation of exactly what the path than
the process that we go through here in
NXT from you know like the performance
and on towards NXT television and
eventually to run smack down so I guess
it's kind of the most real experiencing
it without actually doing it and
becoming a WB superstar yourself since
our pleasure to meet you sir I hope you
don't mind talking to another Irish
person after what happened on Sunday you
put on a good fight but looks like
Sheamus said took the belt home again
well you know he did but you know if
you're as good as I am you know every
time somebody slips the ring when you
just bring out the best in them and they
kind of grow over themselves and you
know that can be detrimental to you or
to me in this case because you know I
don't just fight the guys that everybody
else does I fight them on the highest
level so sometimes it just happens that
you know they grow themselves so much
that yeah you know did you ever play at
video games growing up yourself at all I
was never a huge video game guy but I
definitely had my fair share of video
games what's I like seeing yourself in
the game then consider especially
considering like if you'd seen like 10
years ago you would have been as blocky
ass version where is now it's like and
and that's easy to say because you know
anybody who's anybody remembers the
first create a wrestler yellow and
you're creating yourself and giving
yourself cool names face paints and
tattoos and blah blah and to see
yourself actually on there and you look
like a you look like the Freak you
created it when you're a child it's
something else ma'am and it's it's
amazing like how spot-on
that these graphics are it looks it to
the naked eye if you just glanced at it
you look like you're watching the actual
show and that is just amazing to me out
how far technology has come they make
you do like a full body scan as well I
don't remember doing it but it's kind of
its kind of accurate you know you go in
the air poor and they said just step in
here maybe I thought I was going
somewhere anywhere that we got them they
said oh you're in the game I said that
happened we were talking here brother
earlier and he said he didn't play many
video games growing up did you play much
stuff at all I played every w/e video
game growing up that I could and I wish
that I had more time to play video games
now I guess you kind of you guys are on
the road cuddle on there right yeah
unfortunately oh we're not unfortunately
but like I don't get as much video game
time as I want did you ever do like
create a character stuff to make you
make yourself yeah absolutely a little
bit weird seeing yourself now in video
games at all yeah especially cuz now it
would have been quite blocky back then
where's now you're kind of it's kind of
like decent approximation yeah they did
a really good job I mean I like I've
said in another interview like there's a
small birthmark on the back of my calf
that used to almost unrecognizable it's
in the game that's how detailed this
game is it's unreal in the video game
world I often say that Triple H's hair
was the the sort of the HD experience
now they're saying upside down Bray
Wyatt hair is the new one oh yeah I
haven't actually I saw a clip of it in
the trailer of the spider walk I haven't
got the honor of seeing it in its in its
full entirety but I think I need to go
upstairs and check that out in a few
minutes am I am I darker than Sheamus I
think live like a farmer's tan so this
is actually more tan than Sheamus great
sorry Seamus cork I'll just bigger
muscles two chambers not really okay
thanks very much have you credit where
credit is due you know speaking of
muscles you've got quite a lot of them
and what's it like seeing yourself in
the video game how does a Edison sorrow
in the in digital world compared for the
real-life thing and you know it looks
incredible the video games just looks
incredible and my character in the game
moves incredible because IDK motion
capture for it and i think the stats
could be a little bit higher but you
know how much work does a double-double
super sir have to do like on a personal
level for every one of these video games
like what did you actually contribute
yourself oh and while i did a lot more
than anybody else because you know
better than everybody else but will be
like everybody like the facial scans and
then the voiceovers you know for catch
faces and stuff like that the whole body
scans the gear got scanned all that
stuff and then I went the extra mile an
island it's a motion capture for you
know that this is our swings or a suplex
to European uppercuts and everything so
everything is very authentic when it
comes to zero because you know nobody
else can do what I can so they had to
bring in the specialist you know it's
fair enough did you have to do extra
work on your and your trim that day when
you were scanning your face oh no no no
this is all natural you know I'm not
like Sheamus s2 spiked his hair like
like a guido or something you know what
I mean so um you know concept Irish
warrior and his gel in his hair so I
don't really get that you know this is
all it's all you it's all me you don't
have much hair to jail exactly and I'm
proud of it you know I was real worried
saying that question sir no no no you
know by Hector spending to retirement
early and I did this is a bit right
actually talk about the game but sadly
they didn't allow us to capture any
gameplay or allow Andy to record when I
was playing off-screen so we don't have
any which is an absolute bummer so I'm
gonna try my best to explain what it was
like playing this game and Andy's gonna
have to do some really clever editing
first things first yes you can make
weird freaky people in the my career
mode my dude was tall and pale kind of
like those dudes from prometheus but
with red lipstick and a massive Irish
flag tattooed across his entire body
there's loads of itty-bitty
customization and considering you can
have your superstar invade your friends
career mode there's a lot to be said for
making a real freaky dude or diva the
game opens in a pretty solid recreation
of the WWE Performance Center your aim
is to climb from there into the NXT
ranks and then eventually make your way
on to SmackDown or raw guided by the
omnipresent if badly lip-synched bill
demott I was actually losing my first
introductory fight when it kicked into a
cutscene of my opponent real life
feeding the crap at me for some reason
he was fired and I got a contract
wrestling first thing you'll notice the
game looks pretty great the superstars
look far more realistic than ever before
the crowds are denser and animations
across the board have been improved
unlike 2k14 superstars interact with the
ring a lot more realistically using the
ropes to pull themselves up when they're
tired and falling realistically against
turnbuckles the fights themselves are
credibly technical though at least for
me they felt kind of soulless time
traversing is as prominent as ever and
the overall pace is slower than what
you're used to on TV lots of grappling
lots of ring control and building your
meter to get to a finishing move it
still feels more like a modern UFC game
than the crazy balls-to-the-wall action
of classic WWF games the nasty TV camera
angles from last year's game are gone
and it's definitely had a lot more
presentation work done to it but it
remains to be seen whether the actual
fighting itself is compelling after a
couple of hours I certainly had some
reservations after my short time with it
career modes progression is pretty
interesting though you don't gain
notoriety from winning fights
necessarily your progression is dictated
by social media buzz and the better you
are putting on a show the more followers
you get this means ensuring matches have
good back-and-forth interesting moments
and using fan favorite moves have you
become a good or a bad guy could be
pretty neat to your journey to becoming
healer a face is dictated by your in
ring actions he is telling Daniel Bryan
he's a jerk and acute up cutscene or
something more dynamic like pulling the
pads off a turnbuckle during a match and
ramming a faces face image so it looks
next-gen it's got a bunch of modes in it
most of them I'm not let talk about it
plays a lot like last year and ode to
knww waxing lyrical about hio dynamic
career mode is nobody's really had
enough sit down time to make a proper
call on that hopefully we'll get more
access to it soon but for the moments
WWE 2k15 looks like a game that's trying
to juggle quite a lot and it just might
drop some of those balls I guess we'll
find out soon enough comes out on
October 28 for previous gen consoles and
November eighteenth and all your fancy
new ones